Hello, my name is Jason Blum, and this is
my Must-See October Watchlist.
I love re-watching, The Hills
Have Eyes because it's so out there.
Don't Look Now.
It's one of the most powerful films
in terms of atmosphere
I've ever, ever seen.
I Know What You Did Last Summer, Scream
Invasion of the Body Snatchers.
Look, I grew up watching Disney stuff,
so Halloweentown.
Carrie is one of them
because I remember
the scream that I made
when I saw the hand at the end.
Rosemary's Baby, The Exorcist.
30 Days of Night, Drag Me to Hell.
28 Days Later. Those are things
that I can watch on repeat.
Persona.
It is so psychologically terrifying.
And of course, you got to throw in there
the little Gremlins,
because then it just reminds me,
Christmas is coming around the corner.
So, that’s perfect for me.